[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
france24 daniela blandón ya lista en el
estudio daniela la reserva federal de
eeuu no dio sorpresas en su reunión de
política monetaria tal y que concluyeron
pues sí señor subieron las tasas de
interés se lo digan o se lo di me lo
dijo ya todo ya adivinando seguimos aquí
con las harinas pero tengo que
atribuirle esto al mercado sin agujero
que ya era el que lo estaba diciendo
mire ellos ya daban por descontado que
habría un incremento de la tasa de
intervención que ahora está en un rango
de entre el 0,75 y el 1 por ciento
después de haber subido en 50 puntos
básicos este desde el aumento roble más
agresivo en 22 años y busca controlar
una inflación desenfrenada que ya supera
el 8% interanual eso en su nivel más
alto en cuatro décadas bueno le pregunto
a ni cómo afecta esto al bolsillo de
todos los ciudadanos bueno lo hemos
explicado varias veces acá pero también
conversamos antes con luís gonzález
asesor financiero quien lo explicó
también
ciudadano promedio tiene varias
implicaciones la primera obviamente es
que el crédito se encarece no lo
empezamos a ver ya en las tasas de
hipotecas no de estar en mínimos
alrededor del 3%
actualmente ya están por encima del 5%
entonces eso va a tender a ralentizar el
consumo vía crédito no recuerden que el
americano promedio lo que hace es ese un
deuda para consumir en ciclos pasados
américas o de américa latina
particularmente cualquier mercado
emergente sufre bastante porque tiene
que subir tasas también para que su
moneda no se apreciara tanto esta vez es
un poco distinto de lo que el mercado
emergente se está adelantando un mercado
emergente empezó a subir tasas desde
hace tiempo pero digamos danny pongamos
un ejemplo de cómo esto se traslada al
usuario mire él estaba hablando
justamente del aumento del interés en
los créditos hipotecarios en eeuu el
ejemplo es el siguiente alguien que
compró una casa de 375 mil dólares en
marzo dio una cuota inicial del 20 por
ciento y sacó un préstamo del 80 por
ciento a 30 años que es lo que ocurre en
muchos países también américa latina'
esa persona hoy paga alrededor de 240
dólares cada mes de lo que habría pagado
en diciembre ese es el aumento del
interés
y también en el resto del mundo siguen
subiendo las tasas claro lo hicieron
suiza suecia australia y hace unos días
también lo hizo colombia brasil aumentó
sus tasas de interés el miércoles el
banco de inglaterra lo hizo el día de
hoy todos están en la misma línea en el
caso de brasil es el décimo incremento
consecutivo que hace el banco central
esta vez lo hizo en un punto hasta el 12
75% anual raúl este es uno de los más
altos en américa latina y es que este
país también está luchando por controlar
una inflación que a nivel interanual ya
supera el 11 por ciento claro bueno
dejamos entonces esta alza de las tasas
de interés para dar un vistazo ahora los
resultados financieros de las grandes
fabricantes de las vacunas y por
supuesto esto tiene que ver con la
pandemia de kobe 19 que tanto ganaron
las farmacéuticas mire los resultados
que fueron publicados corresponden al
primer trimestre de este año algunas de
ellas también hicieron pronósticos para
todos 2022
comenzamos mirando a moderna que más
con sus ingresos frente al primer
trimestre de 2021 pzifer estuvo a punto
de duplicar los también mientras que los
ingresos de johnson y johnson subieron
apenas un 5% pero hay que aclarar en
este caso que eso corresponde a toda su
actividad johnson y johnson no solamente
fabrica vacunas aunque esto representa
casi la mitad de claro sus ingresos
ahora vamos a las ganancias las de
moderna se duplicaron en este periodo
las de facer subieron más del 60 por
ciento hasta los 7.800 millones de
dólares y johnson y johnson como grupo
empresarial redujo su utilidad en un 17%
ahora los pronósticos modernas prevé
mayores ventas en la segunda mitad del
año de su vacuna contra el cob y 19
quesos su único producto comercial pues
se espera que la pandemia va a requerir
más dosis de refuerzo en otoño y fisher
cree que venderá 32 mil millones de
dólares en toda la dan y también el
mayoreo de productor de aceite de palma
del mundo suspendió todas las
exportaciones porque claro estamos
hablando de indonesia que es el cuarto
país más poblado del mundo exportador de
aceite de palma y que tiene hoy
prohibido exportar materias primas para
el aceite de cocina así como el mismo
aceite de palma crudo y refinado eso es
un intento por reducir los precios
locales de este producto de primera
necesidad se cree raúl contra los más
afectados estaría la unión europea
porque las compras de aceite de palma a
indonesia representan el 40 por ciento
del total sin embargo el bloque dice que
tiene reservas para varias semanas de
todas maneras los mercados mundiales de
aceites comestibles han estado muy
nerviosos porque la guerra en ucrania
eliminó gran parte del suministro ya que
ucrania y rusia son grandes exportadores
de aceite de girasol y usted lo puede
haber notado si en sus mercados como el
aceite ha venido subiendo de precio 100%
danny bueno cifra el día
69,97 por ciento esta fue la inflación
de turquía interanual en abril esto es
un máximo de dos décadas y está
impulsada por el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania que derivó en el aumento de los
precios de la energía y las materias
primas también por la caída estrepitosa
de la lira el año pasado
donde le provocaría viajar hoy en
directo de una vez me gustaría ir a qué
nervios a argentina bueno argentina lo
tenemos en la mira pero nos vamos
directo a reino unido